排除けど今ですねえっと今日会った優美せ2017が終わって帰ってきたところで
ございます
台場ただいま誰だよただいま打ち上げサボっちゃったならで今日この場を借りていう
フェスに行ってくださった皆様
そして出演者の皆様スタッフの皆様本当にお疲れ様でした
いやー
すごかったんですよねもう枚とじさんの郵政設定イベントをどんどん大きくなってって
もうで買ってきてちょっと
ビビるはやっぱり皆さんとお会いできる行き交いいたしまいつの動画も見てくださっ
てる皆様に何らかの形で猫返せればいいなと思って直接会う気概ができてとても
うれしいですあの楽しかったねありがとうございますでなんですけどそのいう会社の
イベントの中であの
u 1グランプリうん1グランプリでいう企画があって自
さあ時間
なんとか作って1分の動画を作りました
何人かのクリエイターさんが1分の動画を作ってその中で一番続きが気になるっていう
動画を作った人に1000万円が当たるってコンテスト教
あったんですけども裏真里亞が焼いたの
[音楽]
1人ナンバー
サンバーン始めたいの
[音楽]
井島やとりましたーーー
やべーなはやべえを1000万何かに自慢しようって思ってほしい
はい姉優季リセ万円もらったよえーっ男女
ペットが低く費用でしょそれそうなんか
記者があったからなんか結構なきゃ無事点かな
お金がすべてではないんですけどもみんなで一つのテーマに向かって競い合って
コンテンツで無事
優勝できてよかったでございますねほんと僕が出した動画っていうのはですね実際
改ざんに出した仕方も見れてないと思ったら是非
ご覧くださいどうぞ
あっはっはー
また会おう
[音楽]
re ん
おしゃれ姫
where
あああいうえええ
wl いいいいいいです
398 ae roo
ano 迷う暇 ban
[音楽]
alana nao
はいという終わり方でございます
とりあえず女の人の顔見てーなんて思わせたいという作戦ですねこの動画ですねすごい
振り付けとかの僕何も無いただミュージカルぷい音楽に歌詞を自分でつけて男性ってた
人と振り付け考えてカメラマンの方とかに手伝ってもらったりして実際にその
ミュージカルに出てた皆さん後輩とかなんですけど本当に僕一人のつから絶対取れ
なかったそうだったんでみんなの木
力のおかげで僕のやりたいことができたと思っております
ありがとうございますそして次が見たいと思ってくれた皆さんもありがとうございまし
たねえ
問題はここからだあの1000万円マジで当たったみたいなんですけど1000万円
どう使えばいいですかいやー今度に今困っていると1000万円の使い道が最終的には
自分で決めると思うんですけどもまぁ機材とか株とかつまんなすまんな機材買うとか
ちょっとさせんつまんないけどまあ実用的ではあるけれどもまぁちょっと今とか置い
といてなんかこうお揃いことに使えればいいなと思っておりますまあ参考までに皆さん
の意見もちょっと切っておこうか
なんとか思ったりしてるんでよかったらコメント欄で2000万円あったら何度が取り
ますかっていうのを床からコメント欄に書いてみてくださいちょっと参考にしたい
くらいなんで攻めに何か動画制作のためにしか使っちゃダメなんで
私利私欲のためには使えないというのが非常に残念ですはいというわけで私は今動画に
つける1000万円を持ってい
バッハ
入ってるだけで本当に優劣に来てくださった皆様ありがとうございました
明日はゆっくり1000万円の使い道でも考えるわ
[音楽]
me
ni
あっはぁ